ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ครูเรียมกับครูเอกก็เจอกันทุกวันอะไรคะ
ทุกๆวันอาทิตย์ค่ะทุกวันอาทิตย์นะคะ
วันอาทิตย์วันแล้ววันนี้
เป็นวัน
อาทิตย์ใช่ค่ะวันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะครูเรียม
วันอาทิตย์วันที่
28 ใช่ไหมคะ 28 ค่ะ
28 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนค่ะเมื่อเดือนพฤศจิกายน
ปีพศ.สีพอผชเท่าไหร่คะมีผช
2564 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
2010  20  11 ค่ะ
บางที่ถามปีเท่าไหร่แล้วปีอะไรอ่ะ
วันนี้นะคะวันอาทิตย์วันที่ 28 นะคะอาวะ
เดือนเดือนอะไรนะคะเดือนพฤศจิกายนค่ะมี
อะไรนะคะปี
2564 ค่ะปีไทยปีคศอะไรคะศ.
2021 ค่ะ
โอเคนะคะวันอาทิตย์
โอ้โห้วันนี้ร้อน
ให้ค่ะหน้าวันอาทิตย์ร้อน
ร้อนมากๆ
ใช่ค่ะครูเรียมสบายดีไหมเดี๋ยวๆตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะครูเรียมตอนนี้
11:00 น
9 นาทีค่ะ 5
11:09 น
ราคา 11:09 คู่เรียนกับครูเอกก็เจอกันวัน
อาทิตย์นะคะใช่ค่ะผู้เรียน
อาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์
รู๋
ทำอะไรคะทำงานไหมคะวันอาทิตย์หรอโอ้
วันอาทิตย์ครูเอ๋มีวิธีมาทำวีดีโอกับครู
เรียมน้องก็มีวีดีโอตัวเองแล้วก็ก็มีคลาส
ตอนบ่าย
มีทำงานมากๆ
คะทำงานมากๆ
วันวันเสาร์เมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันเสาร์คุณ
เรียมงูมีเมื่อวานอยู่นิดหน่อยไหมคะเมื่อ
วานขออ้วนนิดหน่อยอ๋อค่ะอ่าเมื่อวานนะคะ
เมื่อวานเนี้ยวันเสาร์ค่ะคุณเรียนเขียน
วันเสาร์ได้ไหมคะเอาวันเสาร์ผู้เรียน
เขียนข้างบน
ไม่เห็นเลียมๆๆวันอาทิตย์วันเสาร์
เห็นไหมอ่ะเห็นไหมฮะที่
ถ้าตัวเองไม่เห็น
โอเค
เดี๋ยวเรียมขยับนิดนึง
อ้าโอเคเห็นแล้วอ่ะเมื่อวาน
วันเสาร์นะคะอ่ะ
เมื่อวานวันเสาร์ครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็
ทำงานหน้าครูเอ๋ทำงานที่คอมพิวเตอร์ที่
สูงวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์วันจันทร์
พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์เธอถ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์
หนูวันจันทร์คู่ a ก็ทำงานคอมพิวเตอร์
มะรืน
วันนี้วันอังคาร
มะรืนนี้วันอังคาร
ไม่ค่อย Day
ครูเอ๋มีเบรควันอังคารขอวันอังคารตัวเอก
ก็สบายๆๆและครูเรียมอะ
ไปออฟฟิศวันไหนบ้างคะผู้เตรียมไปทำงานวัน
จันทร์
นี้เหนือ
วันจันทร์
ค่ะ
วันอังคาร
วันพุธวัน
พฤหัสบดีวัน
ศุกร์
วันเสาร์ผู้ชายว่าวันใช่ค่ะวันอาทิตย์
ด้วยวงการอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์ที่สุดนิดหน่อยนะอ่ะนิดหน่อย
อ๋อต่อหน้าภาษาไทยกับครูเอ๋ข้าก็ก็วัน
อาทิตย์
โคเรียมก็โอเคพูดๆกับครูเอ๋เอ๋เสร็จ
ประมาณ
13:00 น 13:00 นประมาณ 13:00 น
ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะโคเรียน
ทำงานพูดกับครูเอ๋จนถึง 13:00 น 13:00 น
ใช่ค่ะ 13:00 นนะคะ 13:00 น
13:00 นเสร็จแล้วครูเรียมจะทำอะไรคะ
ผู้เรียนมีเสื้อมีอะไรคะมีเสื้อ
ตัว
เสื้อ
เป็นเหม็นไหมอ้ะเหม็นเหม็น
ทำไมเหม็นคะ
ผู้เตรียม
เสื้อใส่ใส่แล้วใส่กี่วัน
นี่วัน
เมื่อวานเหรอคะค่ะใส่เมื่อวาน
ใส่
เสื้อ
เหม็นอ้อมเมื่อวานมีเสื้อ 1 ตัวมีอะไรอีก
คะมีเสื้อคลุม
[เพลง]
เมื่อกี้เสื้ออะไรอ่ะอ๋ออันนี้เสื้อเสื้อ
Chrome ใช้แผนแขนแขนยาวใช่ไหมแขนยาวแขน
พี่ดาวค่ะถ้า
เหม็นเหม็นเหมือนกันเห็นป๊ากวางครูเรียม
ว่าวางวางเมื่อกี้เสื้อไหล่เสื้อยืดหรือ
เปล่าคะตัวที่ 1 เสื้อยืดให้ดูได้ไหมคะ
ยืดอ่ะเสื้อยืด
ราคาแขนสั้นอาจแขนสั้น
เหม็นเห็น
ว่าๆโอเคมีอะไรอีก
มีกางเกง
กางเกงกางเกงขาคู่เอกมีกางเกงกางเกงขายาว
น้องหรือกางเกงขาสั้นกางเกงขาสั้น
กางเกงขาสั้นอ่ะอันนี้กางเกงขายาว
อ้ะเหม็นด้วย
เห็นไหมแมนแม่นอาค่ะกูเรียมก็มีเสื้อผ้า
ใช่ไหมคะอ่าให้ค่ะดีมีเสื้อมีกางเกงนะคะ
มีถุงเท้าด้วยนะคะถุงเท้าไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
ครูเอ๋นี่ถุงเท้านี่หนูถุงเท้า
[เพลง]
จะโกรธแล้วก็เปิดแอร์
สาขาอาผู้เอกก็หนาวเห็นแอร์ไปให้ครูเอ๋โก
เอ๋ชอบดูไปดูเห็นไม่ใช่เห็นไม่คุณเรียน
ครูเอกเปิดแอร์หนาวก็จะมีข่าวคบเออแล้วก็
ดู
[เพลง]
เหม็นนิดหน่อย
ผม
ตู้เอกก็เอาผ้าห่ม
ผ้าห่มคำซัก
ซะ
ใช่ๆวันอังคาร
หน้า
วันนี้ครูเอ๋ไม่ซักผ้า
วันอังคารวันอังคารนะคะเมื่อวันอังคาร
วันนี้วันอังคาร
นี่ของตัวเอ
วันวันอังคารจะวันที่ 30 นะนี่ของคุยหมอ
มีนักเรียนบอกพี่เอ๋ใครดีเหลา
อ่าเดือน
พฤษภาคมพฤศจิกายน
ซึจิกายนวันอังคาร
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋จะใส่เสื้อใช่มะมัน 1 วันแล้วก็วาง
2 วันแล้วก็ Y  3 วันกว่าทั้งหมดประมาณ
อ่า 7 วันก็อ่ะสัตว์รักน้อง
ตัวเองเหรอลูกเอดส์ซักใช้มือซักใช่ค่ะครู
เอ๋ถ้าชอบใช้มือสัตว์
ง้อคู๋มีนี่นะ
เตรียมมีก่อนมีอะไร
Korea ใช้มือใช้มือหรือใช้เครื่องซักผ้า
ค่ะ
เตรียมใช้
เครื่องซักผ้า
ผู้เรียนมีรูปเครื่องซักผ้าไหมคะมีค่ะ
อันไหนคะเครื่องซักผ้างูเต็มที่ได้ไหมอ่ะ
ชีสไม่
มีกูเอกที่ไม่ได้ได้แป๊บนึงนะคะโอเค
เครื่องซักผ้า
Korea มีเครื่องซักผ้านะคะก็ามีถุงเท้า
เอา
เสื้อ
คุยเสื้อแขนยาวนะเมื่อ
กี้กางเกง
กางเกง
ใส่
ไงไอ้เครื่องซักผ้าใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะเอาใส่
ใส่ข้างในใส่เข้ามายใส่อะไรอีกคะแล้วก็
ใส่ผงซักผ้า
ผงซักฟอก
เรียมเรียบผงตั้งค่าโอเคอ้าวบางเขนเรียก
ผงซักฟอกรู้
เหมือนกันนักเรียนพูดผงซักผ้าผงซักฟอก
โอเค
คูณเรียมใช้เป็นผงใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะใช้เป็น
ผงผงก็คือเป็นอ่ะ
เป็นผงตัวเองขี้เกียจโกเอ๋เลยใช้เป็น
เป็นน้ำขอ
เรียกว่าว่าอะไรคะกูเองน้ำยาซักผ้า
น้ำยาซักผ้าวันนี้เป็นน้ำมันเหมือน
หมาอ๋อเป็นน้ำ
เป็นน้ำนะคะ
ไม่เปิดนะคะ
อันนี้เป็นน้ำยาซักผ้า
คู่เตรียมใช้เป็นผงกู excel เป็นน้ำอาหาร
[เพลง]
ก็มีน้ำยาซักก็ใส่ใส่ข้างในเครื่องซักผ้า
ใช้ค่ะครูเรียมนักเรียนใช้น้ำยาซักผ้า
หรือใช้ผงซักผ้า
นักเรียนใช้ผงซักผ้า
หรือน้ำยา
น้ำยา R ซักผ้าค่ะ
นักเรียนใช้เหมือนครูเรียมหรือใช้เหมือน
ครูเอ๋อาหารไม่รู้นะคะไม่รู้
ใช่คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะคู่เรียมกับครูเอ๋
อยากรู้นักเรียนใช้น้ำยาซักผ้าหรือใช้ผง
ผงซักผ้าเมื่อกี้คุณครูเรียมข้างล่างโรค
อะไรคะข้างล่างอีดอกกู
น้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่ม
อันนี้พารักค่าฝากค่าเสร็จแล้ว
ก็ก็มีน้ำยาที่ 2 อ่ะกูลืมคิด 1  2 ด้วย
ค่ะได้ค่ะอันนี้ 1
อันนี้ 2 ค่ะก็น้ำยาที่ 2 น้ำยาให้ผ้าผ้า
นะขอซักซักผ้า
แข็งแข่งโอ้ยไม่โอเคก็มือสองเป็นน้ำยา
สำหรับผ้านิ่มนิว
ขอใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะหอมนุ่ม
นุ่มเหมือนคุณหมอน่ะตัวเองมีหมอน
โอเค
นมไหมคะ
ไม่สวยนุ่งน้องน้อง
โอเคดอนนุ่ม
เรียกว่า
น้ำยาปรับผ้าหนุ่ม
ให้ผ้านุ่มนุ่มแล้วก็ผอมใช่ไหมของ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วไม่ชอบใส่น้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มใช้
ไหมเตรียมชอบใส่น้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่ม
มากๆ
ชอบ
หอมงงวิธีค่ะครูเอกชอบไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่ใช้เหอะเพราะว่าพี่เก๋
ครูเอ๋ใดกรินน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มไม่ได้ในกิน
แล้วกูเอ๊ะอ่ะ
ขันไม่โอเค
ก็เลยไม่ใช้มีหนู
ถ้าเรียมใช้ครูเอ๋
ได้กิ่งเสื้อคู่เหตุฮัดชิ่วในคะอ่านิด
หน่อย
พระเอกใช้แล้วที่นี่หอม
ต้องมีสเปรย์ที่
หมอเอ๋กลิ่นหอมมากๆไม่ได้อุ้ย
ก็เลยไม่ใช้น้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มอ๋อ
คำ
อธิบายด้านไม่มี
ไม่มี
โอเคผู้เรียนมก็จะอยู่ห่างๆครูเอ๋
อยู่ข้างๆดูเอ๋ครูเรียมอยู่บุรีรัมย์ใช่
ไหมมหาศาล
สารคาม
กรุงเทพใกล้
ๆสบาย
แกแล้วมีอะไรอีกค่ะครูเรียมเวลาซักผ้ามี
น้ำยาซักผ้าผงซักผ้า
อ่าน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มต้องมีอะไร
ครูเอ๋
คู่เอกใช้เครื่องซักผ้าไหมคะ
ใช่ใช้นิดหน่อย
คู๋หน่อยใช้ก็
ใช้มือสักค่ายชัยเออสักผ้า
ง้อเรียวแปรงแปลงผู้เรียนมีภาพแปลงไหมคะ
นี่ค่ะ
แรงๆมันที่มีแปลงแล้วก็
ใช้แปลงนิ้วเล็กแปลงค่า x ขัดไหม
แป้งจากผ้าก็ใช้แปลงซักผ้าแบบนี้
หมอ
ผู้เรียนมีไหม
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนเตรียมใช้มือซักผ้าค่ะ
เรียงมีแปลง
แรงซักผ้า
เตรียมมีกระดานบิ๊กสหน้ากระดาน
กระดานซักผ้า 5
ก็เอาต้องมีมีสมบัติตอนนี้กระดาษ
กระดานแล้วก็ฆ่าเราบางที่กระดานแล้วก็มี
แปลงแล้วก็
ใช่ค่ะสนุกมากแขนแข็งแรง
แล้วจะมีฟอง
บอง
เต่าเต่าๆ
เวลาเด็กๆนะใช่ค่ะ
รู๋ซักผ้า
3 ชั่วโมง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
หรือเป่าฟอง
จริงๆซักผ้า 1 ชั่วโมง 8 นาทีข้อ 2  2
ชั่วโมงเล่น
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็เป็นซักผ้านะคะคนไทยบางทีก็ซักผ้าที่
มือบางทีก็ซักผ้าที่เครื่องซักผ้านะคะค่ะ
ผู้เตรียมคู๋ขอแช่ Skin ได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะจะ
ขอแชร์นิดนึง
อ้ะ
วิกคูเรียมผู้เรียนยังอยู่ใช่ไหมครับอยู่
ค่ะ
ก็หลับที่ที่ที่บ้านอะไรคะที่บ้าน
เวลาอาบเวลาคู๋
กว่าสีแดงขอสีดำครูเอ๋
อายุประมาณ 8 ปีถึง 18  We
Are อายุ 8 ถึง 18 ปีก็จะมีอันนี้คุณพ่อ
คุณแม่อ่ะแล้วก็พี่สาวพี่สาวคุณแม่
และอะคุณตาคุณยายไปแล้วอ่ะรอบที่ชนิดที่
สาวคุณแม่พี่สาวคุณแม่ก็จะบอกกูเองเหรอ
รักข้าเนี่ยต้องแบ่งมีกะละมัง
หมอเก่งกาละมัง
ที่ 2 กาละมัง
ที่ 3 บางทีมีกาละมัง
ที่ 4
อากาละมังอ่าที่ 1 ก็จะเป็น
เอา
ถุงเท้าเนาะขอ
ส่งเท้าก็ประมาณที่สองก็จะเป็นอ่ะ
กางเกงในอ่ะเสื้อเสื้อเสื้อชั้นในผู้หญิง
ของผู้หญิงค่ะหน้ากาละมังที่ 3 ก็จะเป็น
เสื้อสีขาวอ่ะ
ซื้อผู้ชายก่อนเสื้อสี
เสื้ออ่ะสิอะสีขาวเป็นสี 4 ใช่ไหม
สีขาวสีดำขาวหนูสีขาวอ่าๆอ่าสีขาวสีดำอ่ะ
จริงๆเชื่อแต่อาจจะ 1 ครั้งสองครั้งครั้ง
ที่ 1 ครั้งที่ 1 ที่มีสีขาว
นายนิ่งร้องก็จะสีสี
ฟ้า
สีเขียว
สิไก่เป็นครั้งที่สอง
หน้าเรามานะอ่าที่สัก 4 ก็จะเป็น
กางเกง
[เพลง]
เป็นกางเกง
แต่ว่าต้องสัตว์ของผู้ชายก่อน
ของผู้ชายซักซักเสร็จแล้วโอเคของผู้หญิง
กางเกงผู้ชาย
แล้วก็กระโปรง
กระโปรงผู้หญิงใส่อยู่ด้วยกันไม่ได้
คือต้องต้องแยกใช่ไหมมันกับที่นี่อ่ะมี
ผู้ชายมีเสื้อ
ผู้หญิงมีเสื้อ
ผู้ชายมีกางเกง
ค่ะผู้หญิงเมย์กระโปรง
เสื้อผู้หญิงที่นี่โอเคเสื้อผู้ชายใส่ไป
นี่โอเค
ได้อ้ะ
อากางเกรงผู้ชายใส่ที่นี่รักษารักๆกางเกง
ผู้ชายเสร็จโอเคกระโปรงผู้หญิงน่ารักซัก
ใส่ด้วยกันไม่ได้
เลี้ยงไม่รู้อ้าอันไม่รู้เป็นคิดแบบคนไทย
เมื่อก่อน
เอาบ้านทีก็เลยเอาขี้โกงผู้หญิงน่ะไปใส่
ที่นี่อ่า
อันนี้ดีที่สุดแยกการะบังผู้ชายกะละมัง
ผู้หญิง
หรือบ้านทีบางคนก็จะมีกะละมังอีก 1 อัน
เป็นค่า
ถ้าสำหรับหน้า
r-mar ให้ใส่ด้วยกัน
ตัดเสื้อเสื้อ
เสื้อ
ใส่ด้วยกันโอเคถุงเท้าใส่ด้วยกันโอเค
อันนี้บ้านอยู่เอ๋มีกาละมังหลายใบมากๆ
เวลาครูเอ๋เด็กๆนะคนนี้วันนี้
คุณป้าก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ซักผ้า
เหนื่อยมาก
เหนื่อยมากๆตอนนี้คุณป้าบ๊ายบาย
ไปสวรรค์
ให้
ป้าเตี่ยไหนครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็เลยมี
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็เลยมีกะละมัง
1 ใบ 2 ใบขอครูเอ๋มีกะละมัง 2 ใบ 2 ใบ
ตอนนี้ค่ายเสื้อผู้ชายตาใส่ที่นี่กางเกง
ผู้ชายใส่ชื่อนี่กระโปรงสั้น
นะ
คะแล้วก็ลังมังที่ 2 ให้ระวังดูเอ๋ใส่
อะไรค่ะก็จะเป็นอันนี้ล่ะค่ะของผู้หญิง
ถุงเท้าถุงเท้าคู่เอกก็ใส่ชื่อนี่แต่เป็น
ครั้งที่สองฉัน
คิดว่าคุณป้า
แหวนไม่เห็นแล้วโอเคออกไม่เห็น
ไม่ได้ยินคุณป้าพูดพูดแล้วโอเคใส่รวมกัน
แล้วก็ศักดิ์เย้
ถ้าแบ่งกาละมัง 1  2  3  4  5 เหนื่อยมาก
555 เหนื่อยโอเครวมแล้วซักโอเคโอเคอ่าก็
เพราะว่าถ้าเป็นโรคตรงนี้นะคะ
เครื่องซักผ้า
เวลาโคเรียมซักผ้าในเครื่องซักผ้า
ไม่ตรงนี้เนาะแล้วก็มีฝาอ่าฝา
นะคะอะมีน้ำ
คู่เรียมเอากางเกงใส่ใช่ไหมคะค่ะเสื้อใส่
กระโปรงใส่ไหม
ไก่ค่ะหรือว่าแยก
เตรียมเอากางเกง
ใส่
กระโปรงใส่ถุงเท้าล่ะใส่แต่ไม่ใช่เสื้อสี
ขาว
จะเป็นเสื้อเสื้อสีฟ้าใช่ค่ะเสื้อสีชมพู
เสื้อสีม่วงค่ะ
แต่ไม่ใช่เพื่อสีขาว
ถุงไม่ใช่
ถุงเท้าใส่ไหมไว้ใส่ค่ะไม่ใส่อ๋อโอเค
ก็คือใส่เสื้อเสื้อ
กั๊กสีแดงและกันอ่ะซื้อใส่ไม่ใช่ขอโทษ
กูเรียนเอาเสื้อใส่เสื้ออาจจะเป็นเสื้อสี
แดง
เอากางเกงใส่กางเกงสีน้ำตาลใช่ค่ะ
กระโปรงใส่กระโปรงกระโปรงสีสีเขียวหือ
อ่าใส่ใช่มะ
ผ้าผ้า
ห่ม
ใส่ไหมไม่ค่ะไม่นะคะ
of เพราะว่าบางคนบางคนนะ
มีเครื่องซักผ้า 1  2  3 ก็ครูเหลี่ยมงู
มีเครื่องซักผ้าสำหรับเสื้อกระโปรงกางเกง
เครื่องซักผ้าผ้าสำหรับ
ถุงเท้า
รู๋ดูดูทีวีวันก่อนมีหนึ่งคนมีเครื่องซัก
ผ้าสำหรับถุงเท้าเครื่องซักผ้า
สำหรับ
อันนี้แล้วก็เครื่องซักผ้าสำหรับ
คุณค่าที่เก็บขาววาว
มีเครื่องซักผ้า
ตกใจเหมือนครูเอ๋มีกะละมัง
กะละมัง 1
2  3  3  4  4
ถ.บ่อว่าซักพรมเช็ดเท้าเครื่องนึง
ซักถุงเท้าอีกเครื่องนึงค่ะซักเสื้อผ้า
อีกเครื่องหนึ่ง
เครื่องซักผ้า 3 เครื่องเครื่อง
งูๆคุณเรียมรวมกัน
ผู้เรียนมีเครื่องเดียวอ่าแต่พี่ใส่เสื้อ
ผ้าเสื้อ
ครั้งที่ 1 ค่ะผู้
ชายเสื้อกางเกง
ครั้งที่ 1 ครั้งที่ 2 จะใส่ชุดชั้นใน
แยกนี่ครั้งที่ 1 ครั้งเช่าใช่ค่ะ
ครั้งที่ 3 จะเป็นเพื่อสีขาว
เสื้อสีขาว
ใช่ค่ะอ๋อก็วิถีซักผ้าครูเรียมวิถีซักผ้า
ครูเอกครูเอ๋วิธีซักผ้าคนไทยอ่ะบางคนไม่
เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนกันอ้าไม่เหมือนกัน
แล้วนักเรียนซักผ้ายังไงคะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนบอกว่ามีโทรศัพท์
ฮัลโหลซักผ้า
โทรศัพท์ผ้าแล้วก็เอามีสภาพไอ
หมอ
นี่ก็โอเคนะ
โทรศัพท์ซักผ้าก็จะมีมอเตอร์ไซค์
บัญชีรถมาเอาผ้าไปสัตว์
ก็แล้วก็จ่ายเงินใช่จ่ายเงินแพง
แค่
นะคะโอเคค่ะวันนี้ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็
พูดเรื่องซักผ้านะคะอ่ะเดี๋ยวคลิปนี้
เสร็จแล้วคุณเรียมก็จะต้องไปซักผ้ามาซัก
ผ้า
ตัวเดิมก็เอาเสื้อผ้า
เข้าไปในเครื่องซักผ้าแล้วก็กดกดกดๆอ้ะ
คู่เตรียมเอาไปใส่ก่อนแล้วกดแล้วก็กลับขอ
แค่พูดคุยกับครูเอ๋คลิปที่ 2 นะคะได้ค่ะ
โอเคโอเคค่ะงั้นคือเขาขายเจอครูเอ๋เอ๋กับ
ครูเรียมในคลิปต่อไปนะคะถ้า
โอเคค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายๆสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ
นี่อ่า